make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
i don't know how many of you guys are
following tom taylor on twitter
but he recently tweeted out this image
with an eye and this quote
from batman that said i think things
could have been different
and every indication that people are
taking from this
is that tom taylor's writing a new
injustice comic and i really
really hope it's true because here's
here's the thing i don't know how many
of you guys ever followed
injustice one right like for people who
never followed in justice one you've got
batman and superman who are like really
good friends
and like lois lane's pregnant right and
batman knows before superman even tells
him because you know the plot called for
and so because of that like they're
they're kind of doing this little
celebration
and then like lois lane is like i'm
gonna go check out some weird story or
something like that somebody has said
they have some information or whatever
and she goes missing and so so you
basically end up finding out it's the
joker that kidnapped
her and then batman's on the trail of
like these weird situations going on in
gotham city that there is a
like a hydrogen bomb or something like
that that's missing there is fear toxin
that's missing uh and there's kryptonite
that's missing and it's like what in the
world is going on
and so like once superman realizes lois
lane is missing like everybody stops and
just goes on this hunt for lois lane and
then eventually
like they track her down right that
she's basically in this submarine
and superman locates her and like
batman's talking to superman he's like
hey man hold off you know
don't go running in there and when
superman breaks in there the joker's in
there and then superman sees doomsday
right so superman like starts like
he gets into a fight with doomsday like
punching him just beating the crap out
of doomsday and then
flies doomsday into space and then
doomsday like doomsday dies and it's
like well that's weird and then that
that's when batman chimes in
and he's like it's not doomsday it's
lois lane and what had happened was the
joker had basically taken the fear talks
into the scarecrow
laced it with kryptonite and filled the
room so that when superman walked in
there the kryptonite made him
susceptible to the fear toxin and he
ended up hallucinating lois lane as as
doomsday and so he basically ended up
killing lois lane and his unborn child
after that superman flips like he loses
his mind he ends up racing off right
like batman gets ahold of the joker
batman's interrogating him
superman didn't even stop right he goes
racing through there green lantern how
jordan tries to stop him he blows right
through his hard light construct
flies in smashes the room to the joker's
in and just punches a hole in him and
then from there is like batman you're a
half measure i'm tired of playing this
game this cat and mouse
game with these villains where like
we're reactive maybe you're okay with
like sacrificing innocent lies because
you believe villains can be redeemed but
like i'm not and so so basically spain
goes on this crusade where he becomes
kind of like this totalitarian guy and
you guys remember the debates that we
used to have right when i covered what i
covered in justice year one we never not
really in justice year one but injustice
one
we never really did finish injustice two
which we probably should but when we
when we did injustice one
we had these amazing debates in the
videos right because like well
i was in support of superman right like
i was like i agree with superman right
like if the world was going to get it
together it already would have but the
world didn't so the world didn't want to
right like the american people were fine
with their government being the way that
it was
because they took no effort to change it
right for all the complaining and
although i don't like this and i don't
like that when it came to
when it came time to put up or shut up
the american people were tested or they
were measured they were tested and they
were found wanting they were lazy right
so they just kind of
let the government be the way that it is
and superman's whole idea was if you're
not going to fix the government then i
will and then and then eventually he
started turning it on the people right
if you're not going to get yourselves
together then i will right like there
was the whole uh vigilante group the
jokers who basically modeled themselves
after the joker who suit ran killed and
saw themselves as like a resistant
movement to superman there was nothing
they were ever going gonna do they were
of no threat to superman in any capacity
whatsoever but superman ends up going in
there and eradicates them all and i was
like i'm kind of in support of this
freedom of speech does not mean freedom
from consequence and they and they
learned what the consequence was for
what they were doing and they were
destroyed by superman right so like it
was it was the coolest thing like it was
it was just it was an amazing story then
there were like all these ridiculous
moments right like superman became a
yellow lantern you know and all that
stuff
and like green arrows killed by superman
and like superman eventually killed
shazam
he learned that like harley quinn had a
daughter injustice is probably one of
the greatest comics
ever made it's so cool it went a little
off the rails by the time you got to
like year four
i think it was it was like ah i don't
know about all this but like the whole
arc with constantine there was this
amazing art with constantine and
injustice one and i'll have the whole
playlist down in the description so you
guys can check it out but there was this
whole like amazing section right i want
to say it was year three but there was
this whole section with
constantine and and the whole idea was
that
constantine had of course he had he's
like in a life that more or less to like
try again right you're not really a life
debt but like dragon's always trying to
take him out and so like of course he
has a little girl with him that he's
trying to save and like mixol pitolic
ends up getting involved and so
basically like like constantine kind of
engineers this thing where he's like
you know there's a major threat here we
gotta deal with this threat and all that
kind of stuff and so the whole thing
ends with a fight between mixopetalic
and trigon
and then like they're ultimately
teleported to like the void right this
inescapable
uh inescapable place where they will
fight against each other for all
eternity and then like you end up
finding out the whole thing is a ruse
right like constantine did that
just so he could get away right like
just so he wouldn't have to worry about
trying anymore and then him and the girl
basically just left right they're like
aren't you gonna help us like take care
of this whole thing and he's like no man
you guys are screwed like you guys can
you guys can't get it together right you
guys are
you guys are all over the place i don't
know what to tell you like he just ended
up leaving and going doing his own thing
the injustice line of comics were
awesome
and if tom taylor's coming back and
writing in justice again that i can only
imagine what it's going to be like right
especially because i couldn't really i
don't know if i'd be behind tom taylor
writing injustice if it was another
installment of what we've already seen
because at the end of the day depending
on what ending you chose superman won
right like the whole thing was over it
was done with right the whole thing was
was concluded
one way or another depending on whether
you go with the comic book ending you go
with any one of the endings from the
video games
like the whole thing is basically done
there really is no more injustice
anymore
and to kind of introduce this idea of
batman saying like i think things could
have been different like is it like
injustice from an alternate universe
like nobody knows
what it is right like nobody knows
nobody even knows if it really is
injustice but i have to believe that it
is because i feel like that's the story
that put tom taylor on the map when i
read injustice i was like okay new rule
i will read anything that tom taylor
writes that was that was my philosophy
after reading injustice and
and and i feel like it would make sense
for him to come back because i feel like
that's the story that made him but who
knows
what injustice 3 would be about i mean
what do you guys think it would be to be
honest right like if you had any ideas
on what you think injustice 3 would be
what do you think it would be like
right because like there were so many
cool moments that came out of came out
of all that stuff i mean
maybe it would be like a whole different
expansion maybe batman's the bad guy
this time i feel like it's too easy to
go that route but maybe like batman's a
bad guy this time
i have no earthly clue but i have no
idea but whatever the case is
i think it would be legit right i think
it would be absolutely amazing the real
question here is if they are gonna do it
is it to coincide with the release of a
new injustice game or is one of other
games are they just done with injustice
right is that like the end of injustice
i have no idea but that's the question
is it going to coincide with a new
injustice game even if it doesn't i
honestly don't care because i feel like
the injustice universe is popular enough
now you could launch a line of comics
absent the video games right you don't
really need the games anymore and that
was kind of the funny thing is the comic
was better than the story in the game
right like the injustice gods among us
line of comics
were better than the video games and it
makes sense right because it was just
written so well but i don't know let me
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section right let me know
if you guys are hyped you know for one
thing like let me know if you guys are
excited at the idea of an injustice
three because i can't tell you how long
i've been waiting to see like another
injustice comic coming out it's just
it's ridiculously good two let me know
what you guys think the plot to
injustice 3 would be that's what i want
to know like if you can make up a plot
for injustice 3 what would you make it
would you invoke like all the lantern
mythos and everything like
would you invoke somebody like the
watchman characters right would you
bring in like rorschach
you know or or somebody like that or
like dr manhattan or whatever i really
hope it does not feature the batman who
laughs i feel like he's been overused
way too much
but let me know what you think that what
you think the plot to this to this whole
thing would be
regardless it's an exciting time right
if it's true it's an exciting time but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
now we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
in this town
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you